mon arnaud robinet l'air les
républicains de france s'il est en
direct avec nous bonjour merci de
prendre le temps de répondre à nos
questions sur rt france le premier
ministre a annoncé hier
l'expérimentation prochainement de
l'extension des compétences de la police
municipale vous demander à bénéficier de
ce dispositif pour votre ville est ce
qu'il ya urgence aujourd'hui à renforcer
les pouvoirs de la police municipale à
quel type de délinquance doit elle faire
face au quotidien
oui il y a urgence et moi j'applaudis
les déclarations de jean castex hier qui
va lancer cette expérimentation au
niveau de la ville de nice mais comme
vous savez l'adn des villes est
différent et pour avoir une
expérimentation qui fonctionne et pour
avoir un recul suffisant
il faudrait que cette expérimentation
soit élargie sur leur temps du
territoire national de ce fait je
demande que la ville d'oran ce puisse
être bénéficiaire de cette
expérimentation depuis 2015 on le voit
aux demandes de plus en plus à nos
polices municipales dans le cadre de la
sécurité poste attentats là également
les manifestations en gilet jaune est ce
que donne le mot demande de consult
voyages c'est d'avoir une réactivité et
nous demandent des résultats et pour ses
résultats il faut à mon avis une
complémentarité renforcée entre la
police nationale la police municipale
est donc élargir les compétences de nos
polices municipales qui ont évolué
depuis plusieurs années et injustement
concrètement qu'est ce que cela
changerait plus de pouvoirs à la police
municipale
à quels fichiers par exemple est ce que
vous auriez accès en quoi est ce que
cela est utile
vous savez aujourd'hui on le voit il y a
un manque d'effectifs au niveau de la
police nationale on voit également des
déficits au niveau des équipements et
que nos polices municipales sont parfois
mieux équipés que la police nationale
c'est un fait et nous le constatons dans
plusieurs villes de france
aujourd'hui ce que nous demandons c'est
pouvoir avoir accès à des fichiers
fichier des immatriculations a notamment
lorsqu'il ya occupation illégale par des
gens du voyage à titre d'exemple la
question également de pouvoir verbaliser
dans le cas de la forfaitisation de la
consommation de stupéfiants ce sont deux
exemples qui doivent nous permettre de
renforcer la sécurité renforcé la
sécurité à vis de la délinquance d'une
façon générale de la petite délinquance
qui est c'est moi du terme pourrit la
vie quotidienne de nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui donc cette proposition c'est
pour plus
efficacité plus de réactivité et je
dirais renforcer ce continuum de la
sécurité et à police nationale les
collectivités avec la police municipale
et bien sûr la justice et les acteurs
sociaux notamment les bailleurs sociaux
dans le cadre de la sécurité de la
tranquillité résidentiel un jean castex
a également annoncé hier la
généralisation de la forfaitisation des
délits de stupéfiants la création aussi
250 emplois dédiés à l'action au pénal
de proximité ce que cela pourrait avoir
un réel impact selon vous pour lutter
contre l'insécurité au quotidien alors
sur la forfaitisation la ville d'oran
s'expérimente depuis le mois de juin
comme d'autres villes françaises
cette forfaitisation donc de la
consommation de stupéfiants
aujourd'hui il est un peu tôt pour avoir
recul nécessaire puisque cela a commencé
en juin dernier mais les premiers
résultats ou les premières remontées de
la part de la police nationale semble
bénéfique mais ça ne suffira pas on va
être très clair à résoudre et à mettre
fin à ces trafics de stupéfiants
à mon avis on d'ouvrir d'autres débats
qui sont parfois des débats sociétaux
mais en tout cas les choses vont dans le
bon sens et je crois que renforcer
également au niveau de la justice comme
cela a été annoncé par le ministre est
une bonne chose ça renforce donc cette
chaîne autour de la sécurité notamment
en termes de justice parce que demandent
nos concitoyens c'est aussi de la
justice en tout cas rapide et qui fait
peur aux délinquants à celles et ceux
qui nuisent quotidiennement à la vie de
nos concitoyens
alors vous êtes dix huit signataires
tous de droite
pourquoi ne pas avoir signé cette
tribune avec d'autres mères à la
république en marche ou bien de gauche
en fait les maires qui ont signé cette
tribune sont des maires de l' issue de
la france audacieuse ce mouvement
rassemblant des élus locaux des maires
de toutes tendances confondues des élus
de toutes tendances confondues des
maires de dalles droite des maires du
centre des mers également des locaux de
la issus de la majorité présidentielle
en tout cas la france audacieuse n'est
pas un mouvement dit sectaires qui est
ouvert à l'ensemble des élus locaux
moi je souhaite d'ailleurs que certains
élus de la france audacieuse qui ne sont
plutôt de centre gauche est trop
d'exemples cosigne cette tribune et
viennent nous rejoindre dans cette
demande nous rejoindre dans cette
demande pardon
lorsque la sécurité vous savez c'est pas
une question de droite ou de gauche
aujourd'hui c'est un véritable problème
dans notre société
je crois que ça touche l'ensemble des
collectivités et l'ensemble des élus je
sais qu'à dijon françois rebsamen
notamment est très très concerné par
cette question de sécurité on l'a vu
avec les violences à dijon on l'a vu
également dans d'autres villes
on l'a vu à tarbes cette semaine
également donc c'est la france une
ancienne du territoire qui au conseil à
qui c'est qui est concerné par don par
ces violences auxquelles nous devons
mettre fin et l'état doit véritablement
réhabiliter sa présence sur l'ensemble
du territoire en étant accompagnés par
les municipalités bien sûr merci pour
votre réaction arnaud robinet je
rappelle que vous êtes maire de la ville
de reims